en septembre dernier une équipe de la
cbi ci s'est rendu avec une caméra
cachée dans une boutique apple de
toronto l'objectif faire réparer un
ordinateur parce que l'écran ne s'allume
plus chez à paul l'employé diagnostic
une infiltration d'eau nécessitant le
remplacement de plusieurs pièces
importantes
montant de la facture 1200 dollars soit
le prix d'un ordinateur neuf avant de
faire les réparations le même ordinateur
avait confié un réparateur indépendance
en ouvrant l'ordinateur le technicien
réaliste qu'une petite languette
métallique est plié et qu'il suffit de
la redresser pour rétablir le courant
entre la batterie et le rétro éclairage
de l'écran
il aura suffi de deux minutes pour
régler le problème
non ça me surprend pas on en a nous ici
tous les jours des gens qui arrivent
avec des problèmes non réparable et pour
des fois pas grand chose ça sera à
montréal le propriétaire de la boutique
micro techno nous montre un exemple le
téléphone de clients un problème de son
le haut parleur est trop faible pour
tenir une conversation téléphonique la
réparation proposée par impose plus de
135 $ pour remplacer l'écran et le haut
parleur ce qui va le remplacer c'est le
module complet de l'écran c'est ça en
fait c'est la pièce complète avec
justement l'écouterai dessus donc c'est
très simple à ces 2 4 4 8 8 vie spip qui
remplace tôt en réalité le problème de
son du téléphone vienne une toute petite
pièce de caoutchouc qui est obstruée par
de la poussière
techniquement c'est ça qu'on remplace
qui est juste encrassé qu'est ce que
c'est très cher ici non celle 29 dollar
cette réparation à paul affirme le boss
surfacturer les réparations l'entreprise
soutient que ses clients sont avantagés
dans ces experts certifiés dabo qui
utilisent des pièces officielles
pourtant aux états unis de plus en plus
de voix s'élèvent pour forcer les
fabricants à faciliter la réparation de
ces appareils
surtout que les récents iphone par
exemple sur de plus en plus difficiles à
réparer vous un peu compliqué de
l'ouvrir et les batteries sont de plus
en plus coller dans l'est dans les
appareils
autre exemple elles ouvertes ont des
iphone est maintenant impossible à
remplacer à partir de vous toucher ce
bouton l'acquis
remplacer il fonctionne plus pourquoi
c'est un bouton un appareil donc le
bouton d'origine pour l'appareil
si vous remplacez le bouton d'origine sa
fonction ne sera plus compatible avec
l'appareil donc le bouton sera pas
détecté par l'appareil et votre
empreinte digitale fonctionnera pas aux
etats unis près d'une vingtaine d'états
travaille actuellement des lois pour que
les ordinateurs ou les téléphones
intelligents soient plus faciles à
réparer ici vincent maisonneuve rays au
canada montréal